bello a tutti ragazzi e vedete questi
sono fa vj e oggi sto registrando la
mattina
tanto per cambiare giuro che da domani
faccio orari decenti però da oggi a oggi
l'ultimo in cui ti ho deciso la mattina
promesso ragazzi ci sono delle mappe su
fatti in jarvis
ma cosa devo farlo farvi tutti i 130 si
vola su ragazzi chiamato gioco geometri
dash mi va bene ma ci stavi perché non
copyright e la madonna ma sti cazzi ok
bene la partenza
ti prego
non lo so
no aveva impossibile parterre che lo
giuro impossibile
[Musica]
no si può laddove volare dopo volare
no parka trottola né difficile è bene
che quando sta per partire il persone si
trasforma nella supposta vola davvero
non era preso per il culo
guarda come parole mora
[Musica]
ma questa parte ma certo devo farne uno
che non sia troppo difficile perché
voglio volare siamo ragazza voliamo come
vabbè al buio si vola perfetto che
sembra limbo sto livello paravera
palamara l'anm hammam port col demonio
morto delle macchinette che ha vinto 30
euro per niente non c è ora che oggi
faccio ragazzo gioco non so che dirvi ha
tratto ciò che la maglietta blu giro non
è fatto apposta
c'era ho messo a caso ma [ __ ] la
chiama faccio così schifo ma è la e la
mattina che ho poca skill non so perché
ho trovato uno decente
[Musica]
fino a me ce la fa questo ce la faccio
con giuro la maledizione quanto mi
copyright hanno stupito non avete idea
martino non prenderti miei money che nei
già porca vacca daito pagato anche la
maglietta zio non mi metterò il
copyright sul serio
[Musica]
va beh non è non è difficile fare
sapendo poco si vola simola baffa ancora
ma è difficilissimo
e poi comunque 66 per cento secondo me
non ci arriva neanche al prof
ma c'è qualcuno che ha fatto il livello
normale vi prego il drop e tv un orgasmo
sentirlo adesso raga l'obiettivo di
tutto il viso sarà arrivare all'altro
non ci siamo ancora
se arriva al drop l'ho finito il video
questo è quanto però impossibile sono
meno tiger o michael copps a parte
facile di chi è così
dai dai dai no ma cosa ma data a cagare
ma riescono a giungere il drop si è
piegata incredibile questo questa roba
e va bene
[Musica]
niente porta euro
oddio ragazzo so che adesso sta
succedendo
cosa è successo
ma se non vedo
[Musica]
ok
noi però possibile dai media è
difficilissimo però questo ce la devo
farla qui dato l'alto livello
l'insuperato livello giusto importante
averlo trovato alla fine ogni se ne
frega
ecco
madonna madonna impossibile impossibile
non è possibile che non riesco ad
arrivare al top mi rifiuto è incredibile
che non scaricare altro per ragazzi
impossibile non ci posso credere come
interrompere un orgasmo alla stessa cosa
è impossibile
[Musica]
ma mi sta impegnando al sicuro
ma perché salto lippi
no era facile era facilissimo se
facessimo una frana basse porca eva era
semplice perché non ce l'ho fatta era
semplice maledizione cioè non ho mai
possibile c'e veramente incredibile cioè
io non ho mai fatte a roma e in cui ve
lo giuro è impossibile usciamo perché
non ci posso credere
quindi andiamo indietro è l'unica cosa
che posso provare a pensare di fare
vedere se scrivo animals se esce
qualcosa bene sennò tua sorella
amen succede aiuto
e vabbè il casino il casinò va bene sono
carico
stavo scherzando parti ma non può il
papa al cervello per in più riaci dovrei
riuscire se ci provano teoria
[Musica]
no forse arriverò il drop non lo sento
no
dai dai dai dai frati mytran telai
fratte carico aiuto sul tappeto e quando
assumi degli acini in discoteca store
sta roba cioè non ha senso
ascolta ci siamo ragazzi
possiamo andare vabbè nei casinò
bene raga era esattamente questo che
aspettavo ci siamo stavolta ci arriviamo
altro perché me lo sento
guardali
[Musica]
pietro fa schifo non è vero
ma no ma stai scherzando ma mi prendi
prima cioè no tav è veramente signore
abbia fine il livello altro abba tu sei
scema che ho fatto sei stupido si può
arrivare il proprio gesù mbeki significi
arrivare un maledetto camp nou va bene è
l'unico no era l'unico livello che
potevo fare su convinto non ne farò mai
altri impossibile
e io che pensavo che fuori prima fosse
perde per chi assume arci diceva bene
madonna dell'epilessia e la compagna re
sono questi livelli ci siamo pronti
ragazzi ve lo giuro ragazzi mi sto
veramente impegnato cioè è veramente in
questo io e lo impossibile dopo una
concentrazione mentale incredibile
[Musica]
ok forse stavolta ci arriviamo se si
vuole stiamo siamo siamo davvero in
questo caso è sotto il titolo aspetto
[Musica]
va bene va bene abbiamo raggiunto
l'obiettivo basta per raggiungere
l'obiettivo
c'è voluto un livello che va da solo
perché se noi io non ce la faccio perciò
troppo schifo
[Musica]
thank you for flying cake lei non è che
messo la mano sul mouse che lo fa era
era lì era difficile farlo così ti
veniva difficile fare un livello dove
finisce la canzone finisce il livello
deficiente tutte le vicende
se mi chiama neanche le sa bene anche se
cambio vita avere un sabot già ragazzi
proverei l'ultima perché secondo me
merita la vita della sicuro che in
questa merita
[Musica]
cazzi
pancras face che fa secco ma che gli si
mette a fare di livelli bassi io sapevo
per me possiamo pure qua non me frega
niente per me
in un video sono riuscito a distruggere
geometri dash
non so in quanti video siano riusciti a
farlo ragazzi skill videoludiche 0 skill
musicali
[Musica]
8 è decisamente una migliore del sito di
quanto potessi mai pensare si va bene
basta va bene ragazzi io con del passito
diego concludere il quale oggi ho fatto
dj non ho fatto a youtuber per un giorno
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi spero
che voi arriviate al troppo nella vostra
vita perché importante nella vita
arrivare al drop poi sempre del resto
cosa ragazzi quanto mi piace anche ai
soci ha capito dalla descrizione sono
solo gli spiedi e non ci vediamo a un
prossimo drop da una prossima canzone
dell'estate remixata dio mio quanto è
bello il momento d da c beh ragazzi
[Musica]